Привет! Если вы работали в продуктовых командах, вы видели персоны. Обычно они выглядят так.
Типичная, самая банальная карточка персоны. Анна, 32, маркетолог, путешествия, йога, хочет удобный инструмент.
Фото из фотостока, интересы, которые не влияют ни на одно дизайнерское решение и цель, которая подходит к любому продукту в мире.
И как вишенка на торте — болевая точка, которая описывает вообще всех людей на планете.
Да, это, конечно, утрированное совсем представление, но зачастую это недалеко от правды.
Такая персона висит в Notion, иногда попадает в презентацию и, по сути, никак не влияет на проектирование.
Потому что в ней нет ничего, что могло бы помочь принять конкретное решение.
Простой тест: если вы выбираете между двумя вариантами навигации, помогает ли персона сделать вывод?
Анна, 32, любит йогу? Точно нет.
Анна ведет 4 рекламных кампании одновременно, переключается между ними по 15 раз в день.
Ее бесит, когда нужно больше двух кликов, чтобы посмотреть статус — да, это уже помогает.
Навигация должна быть плоской, статусы на первом экране.
Поэтому персона полезна, когда по ней можно принять дизайн решения.
Все остальное — это просто декорация.
То, что мы будем делать, называется "протоперсоны".
"Протоперсоны" — потому что они построены на вторичных данных.
Бриф, конкурентный анализ, аудит — это гипотезы о пользователях, а не результат реальных интервью.
Сильные, обоснованные гипотезы, но все-таки гипотезы.
В идеале их нужно валидировать на живых людях.
Но на практике они уже дают достаточно, чтобы начать проектировать осмысленно.
Итак, структура "протоперсоны" состоит из шести блоков.
Это то, что будет описано в нашей директиве.
Роль и контекст, job to be done, паттерны поведения, раздражители, триггер выбора и инсайты.
Первый блок — роль и контекст: кто этот человек, какое место продукт занимает в его дне, с чем он еще работает.
Второй — job to be done, я думаю, все об этом слышали.
Вопрос тут: не кто пользователь, а какую работу он нанимает продукт выполнять.
У человека возникает ситуация, ему нужно решение, а продукт нанимается на эту работу.
Это конкретнее, чем абстрактная цель.
Третий — это паттерны поведения: как часто, в каком контексте,
какими инструментами он пользуется сейчас.
Четвертый — раздражители, что конкретно бесит в текущих решениях.
Здесь агент подтягивает данные из конкурентного анализа и аудита.
Слабые места конкурентов привязывает к конкретному человеку.
Пятый — это триггер выбора, то есть как он найдет продукт,
что заставит попробовать, что заставит остаться, что станет deal-брекером.
И шестое — последний — инсайты.
Это ключевой блок.
Конкретный дизайн решения, которые следуют из персоны.
По сути, ради этого блока все и делается.
Если персона не порождает конкретных решений, то она вообще бесполезна.
Как обычно, для генерации персон я подготовил директиву.
Давай посмотрим, как она работает.
Итак, директива у нас называется «Персоны».
Откроем ее также в превью.
Что в ней происходит?
Агент читает бриф, конкурентный анализ и аудит.
На выходе мы получаем три протоперсоны с полной структурой и сводную таблицу.
Просто переношу и запускаю процесс.
Итак, здесь у нас три персоны в готовом файлике.
Давайте по одной пробежимся и посмотрим, на что нужно обращать внимание.
Во-первых, job to be done.
Вот у нас есть Антон — фрилансер, разработчик.
Какая у него задача?
Быстро поднять сервер, настроить и не думать о нем, пока он работает.
Ему не надо его постоянно мониторить.
Скорее всего, задачи у него достаточно простые.
Когда сломается, быстро понять причину и починить без обращения в саппорт.
То есть, гипотетически уже можно из этого предположить,
что какая-нибудь, например, телеграм-нотификация о мониторинге системы ему была бы удобной.
Обратите внимание, что это уже не просто хочет удобный инструмент.
Это конкретная ситуация и конкретная задача.
Когда возникает, в чем его вообще потребность и что он ожидает получить.
Также здесь расписана ситуация и результат, которого он ожидает.
Далее.
Раздражители.
Здесь обратите внимание, агент опять же не выдумывает.
Он привязывается к данным из конкурентного анализа и аудита.
В целом, я отчасти такой же фрилансер-разработчик, который также с серверами работает и порой катит клиентские сервисы,
сталкиваюсь с теми же проблемами.
Да, мне нужен минимальный функционал за минимальные деньги и не думать и не париться об этом.
В принципе, здесь это и описано, что ему не нужны огромные визарды, длинные флоу для того, чтобы настроить идеально сервер.
Нужна хорошая рабочая машина, которая не тратит кучу времени и денег.
Так или иначе, это не какие-то фантазии, галлюцинации нейросети.
Это конкретные данные, которые мы достали из исследований, аудита и брифа.
Далее у нас триггер выбора.
Две важные строки здесь.
Это что заставит остаться и что станет делбрейкером.
Это ваши красные линии при проектировании.
Дилбрейкер – это то, чего делать нельзя, а что заставит остаться, то, что обязательно должно быть.
Я думаю, это и так понятно.
И инсайты или же дизайн импликации.
Это из зарубежного термин пришел.
Здесь каждая строка – это конкретное решение с обоснованием.
Да, конечно, нужно еще самостоятельно критики эти решения подвергать.
Но, тем не менее, это перечень того, что нужно конкретной персоне и почему.
Если у вас здесь получилось что-то абстрактное, можете переспросить агента.
Но, на самом деле, обычно он отрабатывает отлично.
Вот у нас есть еще персона 2.
Марина – владелец интернет-магазина.
Тоже еще одна персона.
И Дмитрий – VPN-предприниматель.
В наше время это, к сожалению, актуально.
И в конце у нас вводная таблица.
Три разных персоны, три разных сценария, три набора требований.
И в конце файла сводная таблица, в котором есть job-to-be-down, приоритет и ключевой дизайн-вывод по каждой.
Ну, еще и дополнительно.
Почему крипта, текущий хостер, количество серверов.
Какие-то основные пункты, которые определяют опыт использования, его направленность.
Что вообще он будет делать в нашем продукте.
Итак, персоны сгенерированы.
Дальше у нас три вещи.
Первое – это приоритизация.
Одна из трех персон у нас должна стать основной.
Это наш пользователь, потребности которого пойдут в MVP.
Остальное – это secondary.
Их потребности учитываем, но не в ущерб первому.
Далее.
Агент представляет приоритеты в сводной таблице.
Но финальное решение, конечно, за вами.
Обсудите с продуктом, если работаете в команде.
Второе – валидация дизайна решений.
Когда у вас два варианта – экран, флоу, фича – прогоните каждый через персоны.
Какой вариант лучше для primary персоны?
Не ломает ли он сценарий для уже второй персоны?
Именно по важности.
Это не формальный процесс.
Тут уже не обязательно с агентом общаться.
Можно просто открыть файл и подумать.
Персоны становятся такими призмами, через которые вы смотрите на свой продукт.
И третье – связка со следующими шагами.
Персоны порождают конкретные решения.
Из job-to-be-дана и паттернов поведения вытекают user stories, которые пойдут впереди.
Из раздражителей – требования к MVP.
Из триггеров – требования к анбордингу.
В следующих уроках мы будем использовать этот файл напрямую.
В симуляции интервью агент будет отвечать от лица этих персон.
Что хочу отдельно отметить.
Персоны – это не финальный артефакт.
Это рабочий инструмент, который живет в проекте и используется на каждом следующем шаге.
Зачастую именно в продукте персоны начинают выдумывать из головы.
Здесь же у нас все обосновано на огромном количестве информации, собранной эти персоны.
Поэтому они, конечно, у нас будут качественнее.
Но не будем забывать, что это все еще нереальные люди.
И, конечно, такого же эффекта, как настоящие тесты и глубинки, они не дадут.
Итак, в качестве домашнего задания все максимально просто.
В своем проекте запускаем эту директиву и получаем этот файлик Personas.md.
После чего просто скрините его, показываете, что он у вас действительно есть и прикрепляете к выполнению домашнего задания.
Помимо этого, обратите внимание на блок инсайты или дизайн импликации, как здесь уже было прописано в директиве.
И достаньте оттуда 2-3 фичи, которые вам показались интересными.
На этом все. Увидимся в следующем уроке. До встречи!